erinnert ihr euch noch daran als eine
ganze raumstation auf die erde gestürzt
ist kein scherz das ist wirklich
passiert wohl nicht hier eine ganz
andere frage wer zahlt man eigentlich im
weltall mit einem ganz normalen dollar
wird das wahrscheinlich nicht sein oder
naja ist ja auch ihr alles egal dann
irgendwann crashte unsere milchstraße in
die andromedagalaxie und dann ist alles
vorbei
ich glaube es ist mal wieder zeit für
hier kommen fünf davon beeindruckt von
den selbst jude ist
übrigens dieses video wird unterstützt
von tax tricks bleibt auf jeden fall
dran dann erkläre ich euch gleich wie
ihre steuererklärung noch einfacher und
noch günstiger abgeben könnt packt
nummer eins eine raumstation iss auf die
erde gestürzt
wusstet ihr eigentlich dass die usa
schon vor der iss an einer raumstation
gearbeitet haben nach der mondlandung
1969 war klar man wollte als erstes land
eine eigene basis ins all bringen und
damit ein neues zeitalter der menschheit
einleiten dieses mal war russland aber
mit derzeit 1 schneller 1971 schickte
die sowjetunion die erste raumstation
der menschheit in die erdumlaufbahn und
erhöhte so den druck auf die nasa skylab
war amerikas antwort und das motto war
typisch usa größer schneller weiter also
eine raumstation mit adlern pick up
trucks und teuren arztrechnung
naja nicht ganz im kern der idee standen
experimente im all skylab sollte ein
riesiges schwebendes weltraumlabor
werden indem man aber nicht nur arbeiten
sondern auch wirklich leben konnte und
das ganze sollte schon 1973 realität
werden
eigentlich ist ein ziemlich geiles thema
für doktor watson oder also ein ganzes
video sollte man nicht aufwachen als ich
mein space kommt ja immer gut an lasst
uns einfach viel draus machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schlussendlich ging aber einiges schief
und 1979 stürze die station ab vier
jahre früher als die nasa vorhergesehen
habe sondern damals hieß es in den
schlagzeilen gefahr für deutschland aber
die blieb aus nur in australien und über
dem indischen ozean stürzen ein paar der
teile auf die erde und wurden dort stand
von ein paar hobby astronauten
eingesammelt verletzt wurde gott sei
dank niemand in den folgenden jahren
wurden kleine wrackteile immer wieder
für mehrere hundert dollar pro stück
verkauft 2016 stand sogar eines der
größten fraktale für 30.000 dollar zur
option falls ihr euch skylab auch mal in
echt ansehen wollt findet ihr die
restlichen überbleibsel heute in es
prinz minister polarisieren in
australien und im us- space rocket
center praktisch nummer 2 wie queen die
erde vor asteroiden schützt weit über
unseren köpfen fliegt sie in ihrem
state-of-the-art superjet mit riesigen
schutzschilder tag und nacht dreht sie
ihre runden um die erde um uns vor
riesigen asteroiden zu schützen die rede
ist natürlich von queen elizabeth der
zweite wahrte das kann nicht sein es
geht um die band queen ja wie gesagt
wenn es denn keiner
[Musik]
okay aber wie schützt uns freddie
mercury vor asteroiden
na ja gar nicht aber brian may tut das
der ist nämlich nicht nur gitarrist von
queen sondern auch noch astrophysiker
kein scherz in diesem informations video
der esa erklärt er wie man mit hilfe von
hera für die erste gefährliche
asteroiden ablenken möchte er ist teil
einer kollaboration zwischen esa und
nasa die nasa schießt in teil eins der
mission einen satelliten in einen
asteroiden um so seine flugbahn zu
verändern
teil 2 übernimmt dann die esa und
schickt dem hera satelliten hinterher um
zu überprüfen ob der nasa-satellit
tatsächlich erfolgreich war und die
mission hat sogar bereits begonnen die
nasa hat ende letzten jahres schon ihren
satelliten david losgeschickt im
september soll er dann in den asteroiden
crashen zwei jahre später 2024 macht
sich daher der queen esa satellit auf
den weg und jetzt willst du noch etwas
kompliziert haben die beiden missionen
sind teil von aida das bedeutet nicht
dass die beiden satelliten eine
kreuzfahrt durchs mittelmeer machen da
steht für ersteres impact and traction
assessment klingt natürlich immer sehr
cool und sehr militärisch mit hilfe
dieser mission möchte man verhindern
dass solche filme wie don't look up oder
armageddon realität werden kleiner fun
fact der asteroid den man auf der ersten
emission von seiner bahn ablenken möchte
heißt die more fonds und der ist
ungefähr so groß wie eine der pyramiden
von gizeh um die erde von solchen
potenziellen bedrohungen zu schützen hat
die esa sogar eine eigene abteilung die
nur für den schutz der erde da ist das
planetary die fans office aber nicht
verwechseln mit dem planetary die fans
coordination office der nasa deren logos
übrigens so aus
von asteroiden die auf die erde zu
steuern kommen jetzt mal zu steuern rein
statistisch haben 90 prozent von euch
anrecht auf eine jährliche
steuerrückzahlung und im durchschnitt
lässt man sich hier mehr als 1000 euro
durch die lappen gehen und das jedes
jahr zumindest bei mir stand immer eins
zwischen mir und durchschnittlich 1000
euro steuern machen ist ätzend deswegen
wird dieses video unterstützt von tax
fix mit touch fix kann man unverbindlich
und kostenlos ausrechnen lassen wie viel
geld man tatsächlich vom finanzamt
zurück bekommt wenn ihr euch dann dafür
entscheide teure steuererklärung über
touch fix einzureichen dann zahlt ihr
einmalig 39 eur 99 außer natürlich
schaut gerade dieses video denn mit dem
rabattcode watson könnt ihr eure steuern
noch mal 15 prozent günstiger einreichen
das ganze funktioniert wirklich
kinderleicht und hat sich in der regel
tatsächlich innerhalb von einer halben
stunde oder so erledigt egal ob am
smartphone oder am laptop und danach
regel tax fixed alles für euch und das
nächste mal wenn ihr was von denen hört
habt ihr auch schon eure
steuerrückzahlung auf dem konto klingt
gut dann sichert euch jetzt 15 prozent
mit meinem kopf wachsen und unterstützt
dabei auch noch diesen kanal vielen
landtags für die unterstützung bei
diesem video und jetzt geht es weiter
fax nummer drei was kostet ein raumanzug
der nasa
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück aus der
werbepausen wir sind hier wieder bei 5
unglaubliche weltraum fakten das quiz
und wir sind in der finalen runde die
letzte frage lautet wie teuer ist ein
raumanzug der nasa
1500 dollar b
15.000 dollar c
150000 dollar oder die 15 millionen
dollar und die richtige antwort lautet
der herzlichen glückwunsch an alle die
jetzt richtig gesagt über 15 millionen
dollar ist das richtig hallo regie das
stimmt ist ja auch scott oder was na ja
tatsächlich zumindest teilweise auf
mindestens 15 millionen dollar wird der
preis 1974 geschätzt aber tatsächlich
kostet zwar einen raumanzug der nasa
heutzutage
inflationsbereinigt sogar noch viel viel
mehr geschätzt wird der preis heute pro
anzug auf 150 bis 220 millionen dollar
denn ein raumanzug muss ja auch nicht
nur cool aussehen sondern vor allem den
astronauten im vakuum am leben halten
zusätzlich schützen anzug vor der
strahlung der sonne der kälte und
unzähligen partikeln die teilweise mit
knapp 30.000 km h durchs all rasen
darüber hinaus sind auch noch
kommunikations und messgeräte verbaut
deshalb klassifiziert die nasa ihre
raumanzüge auch als personal space kraft
und nicht als kleidung
und das krasse ist die einzige die die
nasa heute noch benutzt stammen fast
alle aus dem jahr
1974 und wurden ursprünglich für das
space-shuttle-programm die seit heute
sind von dem damals 18 anzügen immerhin
noch elf einsatzfähig aber für die gehen
langsam die ersatzteile aus falls das
jetzt hier jemand von der nasa sieht wir
können euch gerne vielleicht ein oder
zwei ausrangierte modelle abnehmen so
als idee viel geld haben wir dafür nicht
aber damit sind auch schon beim nächsten
thema
fakt nummer vier es gibt eine space
währung
stellt euch vor ihr seid auf der
internationalen raumstation und wollt
eine runde intergalaktisches poker
spielen oder noch besser ihr wollt euren
amerikanischen kollegen seinen 150
millionen dollar teuren raumanzug
abkaufen bargeld habt ihr auf der erde
gelassen willst du umständlich und auch
gefährlich das ist ja brennbar also
einfach überweisen nun das würde
natürlich gehen aber was wenn das
internet ausfällt und wäre es nicht viel
cooler mit einer eigenen space währung
zu bezahlen die mega cool aussieht und
einen richtig will den namen hat dann
zahlt auch mit quasi eurosprinter
galactic die nomination kurz kit das
sollte quasi die erste offizielle
weltraum währung werden die auch
speziell für den austausch und die
nutzung im all designt wurde das
sind squibb
mehr dran andere währung quaids die sind
genau genau die sind nicht brennbar und
haben auch keine scharfen kanten sind
also vollkommen weltall tauglich designt
wurde die währung von einem forscherteam
der university of leicester in
zusammenarbeit mit wissenschaftlern vom
national space center aber natürlich
gibt es einen grund warum mir bisher
noch nie von kohls gehört hat denn auch
wenn die währung wirklich von
wissenschaftlern entwickelt und sogar
schon in kleinen mengen produziert wurde
war es eigentlich nur eine groß
angelegte marketing aktion eines devise
unternehmens bei so firmen kann man
währungen eintauschen zum beispiel euro
in pfund und 2007 konnte wie das zum
beispiel auch mit kohls machen nun waren
die einfach komplett nutzlos eintritt
war damals circa 65 oder acht euro wert
benutzt wurde die währung nie schon gar
nicht im weltall
der letzte fahrt kommt dieses mal von
euch
sagt nummer fünf die andromedagalaxie
und unsere milchstraße werden gar nicht
miteinander crashen
unter dem letzten video hat uns michael
seinen lieblings space fakt geschrieben
wie sieht die erde in vier milliarden
jahren aus gibt es sie dann überhaupt
noch und wenn ja gibt es noch menschen
darüber können wir natürlich nur
spekulieren was aber michael jetzt schon
weiß ist dass sich die milchstraße und
die andromeda-galaxie auf kollisionskurs
befinden und da hilft auch nicht queen
elizabeth im superjet vielleicht weil es
auch schon einfach zu spät ist zwar
liegen beide galaxien noch knapp 25
millionen nicht auseinander nach
neuesten berechnungen könnte das große
runde wo der galaxien aber schon
begonnen haben bis die galaktische
verschmelzung allerdings abgeschlossen
ist wird es sogar noch bis zu 6
milliarden jahre dauern verschmelzung
ist auch ein deutlich passenderes wort
für dieses phänomen denn crashen wird
hier hoffentlich nichts die
himmelskörper der beiden galaxien liegen
so weit auseinander dass sich die sterne
und planeten der beiden galaxien gar
nicht berühren dürften den galaxien sind
weitläufig einfach leerer raum wenn es
dann mal so weit ist und unser planet
nicht vorher durch einen asteroiden
ausgelöscht wurde dann wird man den
galaxie kern von andromeda nachts als
sternbild oder eher als galaxie bild
sehen können und das dreimal größer als
der große wagen apropos großer wagen
auch ihr könnt jetzt großes wagen und
uns euren lieblings pace fakt in die
kommentare schreiben mit einem ganz
klein bisschen glück kommt ihr so in das
nächste video von fünf space fakten
danke euch für euer extrem positives
feedback ist freut uns wirklich sehr
dass die videos hier so gut ankommen bis
zum nächsten mal bleibt wie immer
neugierig osnabrück
[Musik]
v